do you think men and women can just be
friends
yes yes
I've always said that in most cases a
man and woman can be friends if the man
isn't attracted to the woman no and then
your friend yes accidentally friends
then yeah my girl has a girlfriend
that's okay oh it's true the difficulty
with it is
wait
when it
I would hope my influence would make a
choose the right friends to be with
based on how they can impact our
relationship but I don't think that's my
final Choice do you not think if if a
man said to her let like if she said I
want to have sex we should all the male
friends will say yeah let's do it that's
yeah that was an experience yeah but I
don't know where you're going with that
yeah there was an experiment on YouTube
right this guy stopped couples in the
street and says okay does he does a
girlfriend have a male friend yeah yeah
whatever yeah so okay we'll do it we'll
run an experiment
get the girl
call your main phone right now I've
heard of that and say I want to have sex
with you yeah so you have since you have
male friends would you call one on the
show no and see if you did have sex
exactly no because do you think they'll
say yes is it is it's Primal in a man to
just be like oh yeah but that's that's
what I'm saying like they wouldn't be
friends if they wouldn't be friends with
you if you if you were 350 pounds
they're friends with you because you're
attractive
no guys are that excited to hear us talk
but there are men that like 350 pound
women there's a couple but that's
usually because they can't get the hot
chicks and you see that because okay
Jesse Williams who's Jesse Williams you
don't know who Jesse was grazing out
okay how many times why do we hear the
term trophy wife because it's like a
wife that's a trophy and she's good
looking yeah but they're boring yeah why
do you just assume that because you
could just tell that's probably why they
melt like who give me example of a
choice if someone like them
um Cristiano
Melania Melania does she look like she's
in love with Trump you can have he's got
all power in the world that's a trophy I
mean that's a trophy wife but the shoot
look like she's smart too she knows
three languages oh that's cool yeah
she's no she's smart I'm saying like you
can't just assume just because they're
pretty they're boring to me that's like
a mating strategy though
I'm not a trophy wife who looks really
happy I'm Cristiano Ronaldo's like who's
the one that they that he picked her up
off of a shoe store was that Cristiano
Ronaldo's wife yeah I don't know yeah I
think there's a lot of trophy wives that
are very happy because I almost think
they're happier because they understand
their roles but do you see there were
the media showing us do you think that's
what the media showing that they're
happy
um I I don't know celebrity
relationships are always a weird so I so
I don't know but I'm saying like I I
think when you're in a relationship
where the man and the woman understand
their roles they tend to be happier
when it's a trophy wife like usually I
mean like a girl that stays home and
raises the kids and then do you think
the man's probably oh that's my wife
she's got her role she's got her payroll
she's I'm doing this do you think that
he's gone out and had something more fun
because that's his wife I don't know
well probably no I mean men that make
more money like get the option to cheat
more so more of them do sure but I think
women cheat more than men do you think
his wife is cheating now
I I think it depends I think it depends
but I don't know what your point is like
all all couples have problems just
because she's hot doesn't mean that she
offers she's let like she's boring I
think that's a mating strategy women use
to like like to make them less
competitive does it say that the hot
girl is boring or she doesn't have any
brains or whatever no no I'm not saying
she's not I'm not saying she's silly
yeah I'm just saying that she just I
don't know what she looks like because
it's bad yeah but obviously you know
what Cristiano looks like but I don't
know his wife yeah I didn't have a clue
yeah is she really pretty is she
um I I don't think she's stupid pretty I
don't know I think I don't know I don't
know I've just heard they have a very
like cute relationship I don't really
know
that's what we're saying if you if you
let your girl have male friends then
um it's not you might trust her but you
you know they could they could
disrespect you whenever you don't have
to say but the reason why I can't just
say no is because they're gonna be there
might be a man in her life that has been
so invested in her life from a young age
that she he might have a part to play in
her maybe mental sanity for example so
for example my last girlfriend
she lost both she lost both her parents
her boyfriend was like her Rock
they broke up I can't tell you why they
broke about on the other thing but he
was so instrumental in her keeping our
sanity I can't just now say you can't
speak to him
don't be with her that's just smart wait
by the way I'm the neural wait I'm the
new yeah wait wait can I connect
I just want to understand yeah so so
because he was like there for her before
you allowed her to be friends with her
ex and you continue to date her
yes but the reason why that's crazy
you're a feather so
I was only with her for a short period
of time what I'm saying is that there
was a part of her life I don't know
about uh-huh yeah I don't I didn't know
what she went through but he did so you
want her to be with a dude that knows
more about her life than you no it's not
even nice let them be together it's not
even that though it's not even that it's
a situation where until I was I didn't I
didn't get enough because I wasn't with
her for a long amount of time I didn't
find out about all the history because I
didn't find out about all the history I
wasn't able to replace him
are you friends with some of your access
too me yes no I don't I don't I don't do
you have a lot of girl is there friends
I've only ever had one girlfriend no no
friends girls are friends not really so
the only girl you picked today was the
girl that was friends with her ex
actly I I get why you allowed it but I'm
just saying it won't run with me like
which is which is perfectly fine but
what I'm not gonna do is just
automatically say okay cool because I
know how men are automatically
you can't talk to any man because I know
because I don't because I I didn't know
her past and I did and I didn't give
myself enough time to find out about her
past so I'm saying and she went through
a lot of stuff in the past maybe it was
a short thing yeah I was only with her
for like nine months right so because I
wasn't for a long amount of time I
didn't know all that history to then say
okay cool I can now take it why did you
two break up can I ask for the reason
I'm curious so the reason why we broke
up was because
so she said she liked me but I never at
that moment felt the same way but she
was the first person to ever say oh I
like you so it made me feel a kind of
way so I thought and I would I wasn't
really
I wasn't really taught a lot about this
growing up so I kind of had to learn for
myself right so I thought okay cool
she said she likes me I think she's
pretty maybe I can grow into this these
times I'm going to University so I was
going to University I was working and
I'm an athlete as well so I really had
no free time and what happens is the
level of commitment and attention and
the seeing I couldn't offer it
you you went that into her that's where
you allowed I think the universe
conspired to save you man that doubt it
trust me probably got saved probably but
but because it was the first person to
ever say that I was like okay cool I
actually got excited because me doesn't
matter I don't really get told any kind
of things so I thought it sucks I
thought maybe I can go into it and the
more I'm in a relationship the more I'm
realizing I'm not really on you like
that so I'm saying so I so I I broke it
off because I said I can't give you what
I feel you need so it's better you find
it from someone else
they need to be half hide and did she
did she talk to her ex like the whole
time you were together no no other time
not all like but like like when you guys
broke up was she still in contact with
him I stopped chatting to us I don't
know you don't know like a month before
like if she was still talking to him
maybe maybe I think we can assume based
on the importance he's had in her life
then they probably were talking so maybe
yeah have any of you had girls that were
taught into the access when you just met
them or
um
not I know like if if I'm gonna take it
serious then there's other questions I
need to ask
and if they say yes then
just a smash and pass I guess
what about you
no no what about you no no
[Music]
um
so this is kind of going back to the
original topic we get a little bit off
and we went to Carnival as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible